Exactly when King Henry VIII first began contemplating
having his marriage to Catherine of Aragon
annulled isn’t clear, though court gossip
from the time suggests that the thought possibly
entered the King’s mind as early as 1520.
More concrete sources suggest that the king
began to seriously consider giving his first
wife the old heave ho in 1524, upon learning
from court physicians that Catherine could
no longer bear children.
You see, as with so many monarchs, King Henry
was obsessed to an almost comical degree with
having a son, something he was apparently
unable to do with Catherine who stubbornly
gave birth to a girl in 1515 after suffering
several miscarriages.
As Kings, and indeed many men of standing
in the era, were wont to do, beyond hitting
the hay with his wife, Henry on the side took
a mistress, one of Catherine’s ladies-in-waiting,
Mary Boleyn, in the 1520s.
While this affair is rumored to have resulted
in at least two children being sired by the
King, Henry himself wouldn’t acknowledge
either of Mary’s children as his own.
When two is deemed better, surely three is
best and in 1527, King Henry began trying
to woo Mary’s younger sister, Anne.
Anne reportedly rebuffed Henry’s advances,
taking advice from another future queen called
Beyonce and refusing to give him what he wanted
unless he put a ring on it.
And so it was that Henry tasked his finest
biblical scholars with finding a loophole
in the Bible that would let him divorce Catherine
so as to be able to have his way with Anne.
Eventually such a loophole was found in the
form of Leviticus Chapter 20 Verse 16, which
reads in part: “If a man shall take his
brother’s wife, it is an impurity; he hath
uncovered his brother’s nakedness; they
shall be childless.”
If you’re wondering how this applied to
Henry, we should probably mention that Catherine
was his dead brother, Arthur’s, former wife
who ultimately became Henry’s wife in part
because of a dispute over returning the rather
large dowry her parents had sent when she
married Arthur…
Henry took this to mean that his marriage
was cursed, pointing to his offensive lack
of male heirs as proof.
The pope remained unconvinced and refused
to grant Henry the divorce.
Annoyed, Henry had the archbishop of Canterbury
declare his marriage to Catherine null and
void on May 23, 1533 anyway, though before
this in secret he married Anne Boleyn in January
of 1533.
This, unsurprisingly, caused a schism between
the King and the Pope and set in motion events
that would eventually see Britain break free
from Catholic rule– all because King Henry
had the hots for his wife’s friend.
In the end, this did not work out for poor
Anne, however.
While she dutifully became pregnant seemingly
immediately upon their secret marriage (or
perhaps got pregnant before, which is why
the date of the supposed secret marriage took
place long before his divorce), she had the
audacity to give birth to a girl and then
had a series of miscarriages.
In the meantime, Anne had made a lot of enemies
at court, and they started to plot against
her.
She was arrested in 1536 and brought up on
charges of, ironically, adultery (nobody seemed
to mind the King doing the same, of course-
it’s good to be the King) and incest (one
can only imagine if there was even a smidgen
of truth to that, the King, who had previously
had her sister as a mistress, was no doubt
happily involved…).
Along with this, she was also accused of plotting
to murder the King for good measure.
Which, to be fair, if that one’s true, we’re
not really sure we’d blame her for it.
Her true crime, of course, was not giving
birth to a son.
In the end, she was found guilty and sentenced
to beheading.
Interestingly, shortly before the sentence
was carried out on May 19, 1536, her marriage
to King Henry was annulled as he claimed that
he had never been legally married to her.
After all, how could you marry someone when
you were already married to someone else?
Anne’s head was removed during a private
execution with one quick and clean stroke
of a sword and the King moved on to the next
woman
in line.